For the following example, determine where the primary appraisal and the
secondary appraisal is. LaShonda did poorly on a quiz and became frustrated.
She had an immediate negative emotional response. However, after thinking more
carefully about the situation she realized two important things. First, she
realized that it was better to receive a poor grade for just one assignment and
not the entire class. Second, she realized she did not appropriately estimate
how much studying would be necessary to do well on the quiz. So she knows that
in the future she needs to allocate more time to studying to do well on her
quizzes. Type which part of this example you think is a primary appraisal, and
which part of the example is a secondary appraisal, in the respective boxes